Alright. Welcome to Cloud Native Compass. Thank you
for joining me, Mark. For the people who
are not familiar with you and your work,
can you please tell us who you are,
what you're up to, and and everything else
you wish to share? Yeah. Thanks, David, for
having me. So my name is Mark Borschin.
I'm the CTO of Tremolo Security.
We are a open source identity management company,
so we focus on all things authentication,
authorization,
identity, automation.
I've spent, you know, since 02/2015
working in the cloud native community on Kubernetes,
whether it's writing documentation,
helping folks out in the Slack channel, contributing
to open source projects.
So yeah. Awesome. Why don't you tell us
a little bit about terminal security and what
they do? So open source identity management. So
that means a lot of things to a
lot of people, especially in the cloud native
world. The first part that you'll probably run
into us is getting into your cluster via
authentication. So probably our most popular tool is
Open Unison. It lets you log in to
your Kubernetes clusters whether they're on prem or
up in the cloud,
with whatever authentication system you have. So, you
know, whether that's LDAP, AD, Okta,
you know, Azure AD, doesn't really matter, makes
it so that you can get access to
all of your cluster applications.
So, you know, there's there's koop control. Right?
But your cluster is made up of more
than koop control.
Out of the box, we'll do secure access
to the dashboard, which folks really enjoy. And
then, you know, what are your other cluster
management applications? You might have Prometheus and Argo.
And, you know, all these different apps have
their own SSO systems.
So we integrate that and integrate it into
your identity system. So that way, it all
just kinda works and users don't really have
to worry too much about it. Nice.
So that's cool. Open yours and opens our
project that does identity management for Kubernetes.
Now I don't wanna deviate too much from
the questions that we kinda shared ahead of
time, but I'm gonna dive straight into an
open using question because I think it's interesting.
Like, most people have the Kubernetes cluster. They
get given a KubeConfig that lasts for a
very long time.
Identity problem solved. Yes or no. Right? I
mean, it it depends on who else you
wanna have access to your cluster.
You know, the the trick with
that that kubectl
configuration
file is it's a certificate that Kubernetes doesn't
know how to revoke. So in the certificate
world,
if you wanna make sure that somebody doesn't
use a certificate
that has already expired or you've revoked for
some reason because, you know, maybe you emailed
it to the wrong person, you accidentally checked
it into a Git repo, There's a process
called certificate revocation. Kubernetes
doesn't know how to handle that. So and
that's actually one of the the big audit
findings every year,
when they do the security audit of Kubernetes
is Kubernetes doesn't know how to do certificate
revocation.
And it's probably never gonna know how to
do certificate revocation.
Can I just confirm
what you mean by that? Sorry to interrupt.
Do you mind if I just confirm what
you mean by that? Right? Like, what you're
saying is if
employee x works at our company, we give
them a kube config. They have access to
our production cluster by saying that Kubernetes doesn't
support revocation of certificates. If that person leaves,
their kube config is is valid forever. Right?
It's not like we say, well, turn it
over turn it over with your badge and
your your pass. Right? Like
It's not forever.
It's for however long that certificate is defined
for. So most certificates that Kubernetes
gives you are issued for a year. Well,
anything that changes within that year,
you know so let's say you're embedding groups
into the certificate,
whatever.
Like, Kubernetes,
you can't change that. That certificate is self
contained.
You know, certificate or Kubernetes doesn't have any
sense of users. It's not like most enterprise
systems where there's an object that you update
that says, this is what my user looks
like. Kubernetes doesn't do that. So everything comes
in through authentication. In this case, the certificate.
So who you are, how long you're valid
for, and what your groups are.
And so
when you get that certificate from Kubernetes, that's
good for a year.
If you get walked out the door or
you, you know, even more likely, you accidentally
leak it, you know, because we're humans.
So it goes into the wrong email. It
gets shared onto the wrong folder. It gets
accidentally checked into a Git repo.
There's nothing as a cluster operator you can
do to make sure that that certificate and
private key can't be used to access the
cluster until it either expires
or you rekey the entire cluster.
So that becomes where and I've got a,
you know, I've got a blog post that
gets into the details
on why you don't wanna use certificates for
anything besides break glass in case of emergency.
I did talk about it at Kubernetes security
days couple years ago or security con, whatever
they're calling it these days. But, yeah, certificates
like break glass in case of emergency. You
know, you get your cluster, you know, that
shiny new certificate.
You go put it in a vault somewhere
that nobody has access to unless everything's gone
haywire.
And then you use,
you know, I my preference is OpenID Connect
or impersonation to access your cluster. So that
way, you're letting your identity system drive
who has access rather than trying to own
that all yourself as a cluster operator. Nice.
I mean, I I could go into that,
but I don't know if I would not
to be the where we go in this
survey, but maybe I'll ask the questions. And
if we decide to strip it out later,
we could do that. Sure. It sounds like
there's definite there's maybe two trains of thought
here for what people could do. Where they
have this KubeConfig and someone leaves their company.
This this to me feels like a real
problem that we should probably strive. And there
are solutions, of course, you know, open use
and then other tools. But, you know, with
the straightforward KubeConfig thing, are there any admission
controllers out there that can start to block
access based on that authentication model because we
know that that person or that key has
left? Or maybe a second approach is, like,
can we change the default,
time to live on service account tokens issued
by the Kubernetes cluster?
I mean, you can change the time to
live on service account tokens.
Service account token
expiration is still pretty new.
It became the default in 01/2024,
but
if you give
so it it depends on the way the
service account is generated
or the token is generated. If the token
is generated using the token request API and
what's called projected
directly into your pod So that's the service
account when your pod fires up. You go
to, what, the far run Kubernetes secrets, I
think. That token now has an expiration date.
If you try to use
that token after the expiration date, you'll get
a warning. They'll still be accepted by default
unless the pod that it was projected into
was deleted.
So I think it's one hour
is the default right now for service account
tokens.
But let's say you instead had it for,
you know, I think ten minutes is the
minimum, which is actually what I like to
go with, to be honest. But I'm in
security, and I'm paranoid.
So let's say you have that ten minute
service account token and that gets leaked, but
the pod
is still running, you can still use that
service account token against the cluster by default.
Now that'll eventually change, but because
expiring
service account tokens
And mind you also point out, you should
never ever use a service account token when
talking to your clusters. It was never designed
that for that. It was always designed for
pod identities.
It was never designed
to be able to hand to an external
system the way you might a certificate. So
that's a that's another part of that. But,
you know, the the big issue with a
lot of
these questions around
in cluster are the things that we can
do or features that can be added to
Kubernetes in order to
get around a lot of these issues
are
the fact that that would require the type
of interaction and integration with things that you
don't really want Kubernetes to be in charge
of. So think about it from a standpoint
of, well, why doesn't Kubernetes just have users?
Right? And why can't we just attach a
password to it? Okay. How do you get
the password to the user securely? Are you
gonna email it to them? Like, are you
gonna have a human email it? Are you
gonna have an external system email it? Most
passwords required to be reset periodically.
And quite frankly, I don't want you using
password anyway. I want you using MFA.
So now is the how are you gonna
get that second token? You know, or you
can type it in. That's phishing
susceptible. You wanna use a hardware token. Okay.
Well, that means that that needs to be
built into Kube control. You know, we haven't
even gotten to the point. So
folks who are used to using, for instance,
smart cards to log in to infrastructure. So
US federal government mandates it. I imagine there
are probably more governments as well that mandate
it. But that's a a standard called p
k c s 11, being able to talk
to that smart card to use that. You
can't do that with Kubernetes,
and they won't implement it. Like, SIGAuth has
said, you know, there have been a couple
of caps open to do it, and it
just it's something that's not because the the
thing is that the CA
that your cluster uses isn't designed to generate
authentication certificates for users. It's meant to generate
authentication certificates for kubelets
and for other pieces of the infrastructure.
So we're we're trying to use this infrastructure
designed for machines with humans,
and that interaction is very, very different. And
you don't want Kubernetes to have to start
owning all those different integration points.
Okay. So I think it could be interesting
just to confirm a few things there for
the audience and actually for myself because I
made a bit of a full path there
that you kinda corrected me on, but very
politely,
is that I have a straight to service
account tokens. But, actually, if we're talking about
couplets and API servers and schedulers, they communicate
over the API server with x five zero
nine. Right. But I believe service account tokens
are are JWTs that are projected onto pods.
Yes. Okay. Perfect. So
yeah. It it's complicated. I mean, there there's
a lot of nuance in there that a
lot of people don't you know, even experts,
you know, don't always keep track of.
Yeah. I mean, we're in 2023 and, you
know, off end and off set are still
things that are are difficult for one.
And they're just I don't think they're ever
really gonna get easier because,
you know, hackers
exist. People are always gonna try to exploit
whatever system we put in place, which means
they're always gonna circumnavigate the protections we think
we we have in place. And our posture
is always gonna have to continue to evolve.
So, yeah, fun fun times always. Yeah. I
mean, the the key to me is making
it easy. Like, it it's just gotta be
easy. It's gotta be simple. Easy and safe?
Sure. Why not? I mean, I've I'll be
honest. I've got customers
that I'll securely log in to my Kubernetes
dashboard for them on this thing using a
strong token.
If I if I need to you know?
But, you know, I can have a
FIDO two hardware token on this,
even better, on my iPad.
You know? It's a hardware token. It's biometric.
So I've gotta use my my fingerprint to
log in. It's a combination of that and
a strong credential,
and I'm working on my dashboard. I don't
need coop control. I don't need you know?
Yeah. I'm not doing major deployment work,
but if I've gotta check the status of
some pods or I've gotta, you know, kick
off a cron job or something,
That's a really easy way to do that,
and it's secure.
The the the tokens are only good for
a minute. So if somebody gets a hold
of that token,
you know, it leaks in one of a
bazillion different ways. By the time they have
it, unless they're, like, sitting there waiting to
get it, by the time they have it,
it's useless.
So there there are a lot of things
we can do to make it a lot
easier. You know, easy,
that's relative. Right? But easier,
you know, if if I can make it
so that accessing clusters is second nature, which
from a security standpoint,
I I think that goes a long way
to be able to to make users more
secure.
Awesome.
Well, you know, we're fifty minutes into this
episode. We haven't covered any of the questions
that we we planned and prepared.
I think with Fidelity, it's a good taste
of what we're sort of getting. Typical day
at the bar.
Exact exactly.
Alright. I'm gonna jump around the questions a
little bit just because there there are a
few things I wanna cover and, you know,
we we know what those are, but we've
already talked about, you know, tokens, short lived
tokens. You're talking about authentication.
And this is a topic that I've seen
you speak about recently. Right? When you were
doing pipeline identity at QPuddle in Toronto just
last week. Wish we were both there. It
was great to kinda hang out in person.
So maybe you could talk about
what the this, you know, what's that talk
about? Why are we looking at tools like
OIDC? How do these improve our posture, and
why should people start taking this technology a
bit more seriously? Yeah. So
pretty typical use case in the Kubernetes world,
you say, well, I and this is one
I hear a lot. I don't want users
talking in my cluster. I want pipelines talking
in my cluster. Okay. Great. So how is
your pipeline authenticating to your cluster? Oh, I
give it a service account token. Service account
tokens don't expire by default.
So you're you're kind of back to that
certificate place. Like, you can delete a service
account
from the API server, but, you know, you
have to have that process in place. You
have to rotate. You have to get that.
Service accounts were never designed to work that
way. And so the point of the talk
was, alright. If that's the anti pattern,
how do I get my pipelines to talk
securely
to my clusters?
So we presented two approaches.
The first was let's pretend we're a user
and do it that way. So we demoed
a GitHub actions pipeline,
authenticating to an Okta identity provider using a
service account
for the folks not on YouTube. I'm using
my cody fingers.
You know, not a Kubernetes service account, but
just a generic service account inside of Okta.
I log in to open Unison. I get
my tokens, and I interact with my cluster
the way I would with,
like, any other user. And so the nice
thing about that approach is we're not using
certificates.
We're using short lived tokens for interacting with
the cluster. But the major downside is now
I'm building this custom automation
between OpenUnison
and Okta.
You know, it's 10 lines of Python, which,
you know, big deal, but Okta changes its
login process
now that Python's broken. And, of course, I
I mentioned MFA and how important MFA is
before. Right? I I said that. So, you
know, okay. Now I have a credential where
I've disabled MFA.
Like and there are ways you can still
automate MFA. You can do it with, like,
TOTP,
which is the venerable Google off, you know,
your six digit code. That's relatively easy to
automate, but still it's it's clunky.
So it's better but ain't great.
The font the what the last thing that
we demoed was this idea of using your
workflow identity. So just about every identity or
workflow system, GitHub, GitLab, they all have their
own sense of identity.
And so what that usually means is a
JWT that is injected into the workflow,
usually is an environment variable that you can
then use
to identify yourself to your workflow API, but
you can also use that to identify yourself
to external APIs like a Kubernetes cluster.
So what we did was we set up
a project that we built called CICD
proxy.
It's a
it's a deployment of the Kubo IDC proxy
with specialized Helm charts specifically for this use
case where it sets up an impersonating proxy.
So, in Kubernetes, what impersonation means is you
authenticate however you want on the front to
a reverse proxy like an NGINX or something
like that. And then you there are special
headers
that get added to the request going down
to,
the API server. And when the API server
sees it, it does it on behalf of
the impersonated user.
So
my workflow can be authorized
to very specifically
update the deployment as an example. And so
the nice thing about that is now
there is no shared secret. The CICD proxy
is pulling in what's called the OIDC discovery
document. So that says, you know, who's issuing
these tokens and what public keys do I
use to verify it. The token itself is
short lived. I think they're good for power
on GitHub by default, which as these things
go is pretty short lived. And there's no
shared secret. There's nothing to to to lose.
And if GitHub
decides to rotate its secrets,
we'll pick it up because we're just pulling
it out of an OIDC discovery document.
Yeah. I wanna make sure I understand how
this works. I mean and I have I've
configured this before, so I'm gonna try and
apply this as an example. Right? What we're
seeing here what you're seeing is
that we have GitHub who has this authentication
system. They understand identity. They know when you're
logged in because you've logged into their system,
hopefully, with MFA.
So there's a sense of trust there. Right?
Now GitHub published their public keys. And I
think what that means is what we're saying
is when we get that job from GitHub
actions, say, which is saying with the GitHub
key and is identifying as a user, it's
got a UID, a subject, whatever that is
in the job. When we get that and
verify it's saying with the public key that
we know to be GitHub, we can make
some assumptions that we trust as this user
Rawkode from GitHub.
And as such, we allow that user to
map or impersonate another role within the other
side of the wall.
It's a little simpler than that. You can
do it that way. But so every GitHub
action, every run has a a JWT that
identifies
the workflow. So your your username
in JWT Parlance, it's called the sub attribute
or the subclaim.
And it's I forget what it is off
top of my head, but it's like organization
slash
project slash repo
branch,
something like that. But it includes kind of
that critical information you would think makes a
a branch inside of a project unique.
And so that JWT says it was issued
by GitHub. It's audience
and
GitHub's unique in that or in that it
lets you actually generate a correct audience specific
for
external systems. So Alex Ellis had written some
code that showed how to do this where
you can get a custom audience. It wasn't
particularly complicated,
but,
I wanted it to be a GitHub action.
So I took what I learned from him
and
created a GitHub action that we published,
in the marketplace so that this is just
a one line call.
But that actions
generates a JWT that says,
signed by GitHub
for your cluster, whatever you said your cluster
is called.
It was generated at this time. It expires
at this time. And, also, don't use it
before this time because, you know, clock skews.
Right? And so now when I receive that
token,
the c the the Kubo IDC proxy says,
alright.
Was it signed by one of these keys
from the issuer? Yes. Good. Is it for
my audience? Is it for me? Because I
don't wanna accept in a token for somebody
else. Yes. Good. Has it expired?
No. Perfect.
So now I take those claims.
And for workflows, it's simply just the sub.
You don't generally get groups out of workflows.
And that's the user ID that I now
send to the API server. So
when I generate a deployment patch and I
send the request down,
that patch
HTTP
command contains an authorization header,
which includes
my reverse proxy's
identity because that's the thing doing the impersonation.
And then it also includes an header called
impersonate dash user
for
my workflow. So, yeah, Trello security slash
some workflow
ref main.
The API server takes that and looks for
RBAC rules that associate
with my
impersonated user
to make sure that I'm allowed to do
the things that I'm trying to do, authorizes
it, and then does the work. Then when
you look in your API server logs,
the event will have two identities.
They'll have the identity
of the reverse proxy,
and you'll have the identity of the impersonated
user.
So that way you can track
what work was done by who even though
it was done on behalf of the workflow.
It wasn't done
using the workflow's identity directly to the API
server. Nice.
There's a lot going on there. There is.
But you know what? It's understandable,
especially when you have someone like yourself that
can walk us through the process and how
it works. And I feel like I've already
learned
quite a lot in the first twenty minutes
of this episode. So awesome.
Alright.
Let's actually talk about what we were gonna
talk about now. So the last time we
spoke, you actually dropped on this little nugget
of knowledge that I didn't know before. And
it's that you wrote a book on Kubernetes
and the enterprise.
And what I'd love to know is how
you ended up writing a book.
It's not an easy commitment to take on.
Like, I've
I don't know who in the right mind
would go, yeah. Let's write a book. And
not only write a book, write a book
about Kubernetes.
There's, like, two strikes. And then third, I'm
gonna write a book about Kubernetes on enterprise.
Like, three strikes. Like, what the hell were
you thinking?
I'm a glutton for punishment.
So
how I got into the book was
my coauthor. So I coauthored the book with
a gentleman named Scott Zorovich,
and he is also a customer of mine.
So he's a customer of Trimble Securities,
and he was working on another book
that he was asked to do a
review of.
And so he was doing a review of
the book, and they really liked the feedback
he was giving. And they're like, you know,
you really know your stuff. Would you like
to write a book?
And
so he said, yeah. That sounds like fun.
And so he started looking at, you know,
what goes into enterprise Kubernetes.
You know, he works at a big bank,
and he wanted to you know, what are
the things that he cares about day to
day from running large scale Kubernetes clusters? Right.
Yeah. We all talk about things like, you
know, service mesh,
all these real sexy things, but, you know,
nobody's like, backups.
Oh,
I want that.
And so, you know, it was what are
those things that, you know, load balancers. Oh,
I really wanna see those.
And so he wanted to get into, you
know, some of that nitty gritty that, you
know, the enterprise world's just a little bit
different.
And
so we started chatting, and he's like, you
know, I wanna you know, what do you
think about this? What do you think about
that? And then after about an hour conversation,
he's like, oh, this is stupid. Do you
wanna co write it with it?
I was like, yeah. That actually sounds kinda
fun. And so that's how I actually got
signed on to coauthor the book. You know,
for any aspiring authors out there, I will
tell you you're not gonna make a lot
of money off of it. It basically fuels
my cone of coffee habit,
but that's about it. But, you know, it's
it's it's fun. It is a lot of
fun to do. And then,
you know, coming from an enterprise background, you
know, our customers are enterprises.
My customers, you know, even back in my
private consulting days were enterprises for the most
part. So, you know, we kinda looked around
and said, enterprises
are a little bit different. They're siloed.
Right? That that's a big thing. You've got
a service provider. You know, we always talk
about these hyperscales or these big service providers
like, you know, Uber and Spotify and Netflix
and where everything driven is to this one
thing. Right? It's delivering the video, delivering the
food, delivering the person, whatever. Right? But, like,
everything
drives into that one thing.
Whereas enterprises,
you have
thousands of silos
that can be anywhere from
a couple dozen users to a couple thousand
users.
And to the people in those silos,
what they're working on is the most important
thing and the most mission critical thing in
the world because that's what they get paid
for.
And so
when you deploy something like Kubernetes,
and I know the DevOps gods will strike
me down for saying silos are a good
thing,
but that that's just the reality of enterprises.
Everything's siloed because that's management structure
is a silo, silos of silos of silos.
And so we wanted to build a a
Kubernetes book that addressed
the technology from that perspective.
So,
it's not really a beginner's book.
I will give Scott really big props. He
wrote scripts to be able to use Kine,
Kubernetes and Docker for folks that aren't aware,
where we use Kine
for
almost all of the workshops and the demos
inside of the book and all the hands
on stuff. And, like, I use it every
day. Like, I'm like, okay. I need a
cluster. I'm gonna go run Scott's script and
boom. I have a kind cluster up and
running.
So load balancers, authentication, we get into using
OPA,
Gatekeeper.
We dive into GitOps,
backups,
Falco.
The last chapter,
we do,
we actually build out a namespace as a
service with GitOps. So Argo,
OpenUnison,
Tekton,
and GitLab, and building it out so that,
you know, you can log in, request act
you know, request the namespace get created.
It generates all the Git repos and everything.
So it really dives into
a lot of the nitty gritty, and and
it's more than a cookbook,
but it or it's more than a theory
book, but it's not quite a cookbook.
Like, we didn't wanna say here are specific
recipes to use.
We wanted to say,
here are common use cases and common things
that you see in an enterprise. Here's how
we're tackling them and why,
and here are the exercises that you can
use
to to
kinda get your cause sharp on it. Nice.
I mean, based on all the things that
you've just kind of listed there, but what's
covered in the book, the topics.
And, like, if we were to draw a
Venn diagram for, like, shut this important for
the enterprise Kubernetes customer and then shut this
important for your regular Kubernetes,
you know, technology company
Kubernetes customer. Like, there a lot of that
is right in the center. Like, it's still
applicable to people on both side.
You know, the obviously, the communication structures, the
legacy procedures,
backup and restore Doctor, it's gonna be slightly
different on the enterprise side. It sounds like
there's a lot of value for just anyone
who's in this Kubernetes space that that still
wants to handle get ups and backups and
load balancers and, you know, those are all
nice words to me. I like those words.
Yeah. I there is definitely a big center
area.
I think where
the change
where where the edges are, where where that
overlap isn't,
is a lot of it is around things
like policy,
you know, stuff that we, you know Yeah.
I don't like that word. Yeah. People don't
like that word. I'm a security guy, and
I don't like that word.
But policy,
you know, checking the box, it it you
know, we all joke about it, but we
have to do it. We have no choice.
Sometimes legally, we have to do it. And
making it so that there's a a
understanding control. So give me an example.
A lot of folks will say to me,
well, my cluster runs in pick your favorite
cloud,
and that cloud has its own IAM.
Why wouldn't I just use that cloud's IAM
for authentication?
And the reason is
or the question is, do you wanna be,
as the cloud team, responsible
for when something doesn't work that you don't
have control over? In this case, authentication and
authorization.
So if
I'm running an AWS cluster as an example,
EKS. Right? I get that little config map.
So so for folks that don't use EKS
or or aren't aware, EKS has a config
map that it uses for RBAC authorization.
So that that's where you define your IAM
roles that are authorized and you map it
to users and groups that then Kubernetes uses
for our back.
Well, do you wanna be do you, as
the cloud team, wanna be responsible
for that?
Sometimes the answer is yes because of the
way the organization is. And I find that
a lot of times in service providers,
that answer is yes because of the way
that silos have been streamlined.
But in enterprise world, do you wanna be
the one that gets called into a meeting
every time there's a problem even if it's
not your fault? But you still have to
defend your team and your situation.
So what I'll often find, and this is
true of any centralized service,
where the first implementation is this attempt to
build this really stringent
like, this is our vision. This is how
it's going to work. It's a product. Again,
folks listening at home using my coding fingers.
And then the problem becomes
all these little corner cases that come up,
and
you're not able to handle it. And now
you're going in front of the you know,
it might be the CIO, my director, whatever.
But they're saying, hey. This is your fault
because I don't have access to be able
to fix these things. And so you get
a pendulum swing where it says, you know
what? I don't want anything to do with
this. Everybody gets cluster admin.
Cluster admin for everybody. Right? And then security
is your problem. And so now you get
this big other swing where it's like, okay.
We're gonna leave everything completely open, and I'm
sure it'll be fine. What's the worst that
could happen? And so that's where, you know,
authentication
and being able to say, you know what?
I'm gonna delegate to something that you own
so that you can make your own authorization
decisions.
We'll still enforce the authorization decisions,
but you're gonna be responsible for making those
decisions.
And so that's how you then split that
particular baby in saying, I'm gonna continue to
manage and own the cluster operations,
but I'm gonna allow the people in charge
of my customer that's in charge, the users,
the the app admins,
to control who needs and has access and
when. And that that to me is the
big difference between an enterprise implementation
and
most service provider based implementations.
Awesome. So, you know, we're talking about identity
and security and all this fun stuff. Right?
This is I mean, I've seen a lot
of trends, and I'm sure you've seen them
too over the last six or seven years
with Kubernetes
with service mesh being huge and then get
ups being huge. And then there's a least
uptake in open policy,
but it kinda got railroaded by the security
and supply chain,
not movement, but huge rock rolling down the
hill in the energy on sale to the
entire Kubernetes community. You know, even at KubeCon,
you said, you spoke at the SecurityCon. It's
got its own day now, but not only
did it have its own day, it had
the security village, but it had even more
talks throughout the conference.
So it it's very hard to to get
away from what's happening with supply chain security
identity and policy. And I'm curious, you know,
you've you've been on this a long time.
You've seen everything progress and hopefully improve.
But how has the landscape evolved over the
last twelve months, and and what needs to
happen over the next twelve months to get
us in to quote, unquote, a good position?
Are we already in a good position?
How do you wanna tackle that? We're not
in a terrible position. We're probably
not in a worse position.
You know, automation's
always gonna be a double edged sword. Right?
Because it makes it much easier to do
things, which means it makes it easier to
do security, which you have to do the
security.
Right? You know, supply chain specifically,
you know, I I kinda look at supply
chain in two different aspects. Like, there's two
really important aspects of supply chain security.
There's the
security of the image. Right? How many CVEs?
How many known vulnerabilities
are in your images? Like, that's
you talk to any security expert. The first
thing they're gonna tell you is most breaches
are because of unpatched
known vulnerabilities. It's not some, you know, state
actor who, you know, figured out how to
break into your cluster because there's a team
of a thousand hackers figuring out it's you
know, they bought a vulnerability off of someone
that, you know, from three years ago that
never got patched, someone said, oh, I can
use this.
And so that's one that is
easy for most people to conceptualize.
Right? I have an image. I need to
keep it updated. How do I do that?
And there are lots of great tools for
for doing that.
But the other side of it is it
becomes an identity problem. So,
Sigstore
is a great example. This is a really
interesting technology to me. So what the folks
at Sigstore did,
ChenGuard, the name of the company, created this
project where they said, alright. We're gonna do
image signing. So that way, you know that
the image you're running was the one that
you built.
That's great.
Right? But what's really interesting about what they
did was they said, okay.
We're not gonna make it about keys anymore
in the you know, because we've doing artifact
signing for what? Thirty years?
But, you know, if the signature was invalid,
we just hit continue and kept going anyway.
Right? I mean, it it it had no
meaning. So what they did was they said,
okay. We're gonna make the certificates
just a mechanism,
but not the important part.
So when you sign an image using cosign,
you authenticate to the cosign server, the CA,
which gives you a temporary certificate, a short
lived or ephemeral, whatever you wanna call it.
Think it's good for ten minutes, key pair
that
you then use to sign your container.
You then also write that information into a
transparency law. So what you're validating from a
policy level and from a signature level, yes,
you do the cryptographic stuff,
but really what you're validating is the identity
of the signer. It's no longer about the
key.
The key is inconsequential.
It's the identity of the signer that becomes
important.
So if the identity of the signer is
important,
then you now have to go back through
your infrastructure and make sure
that that identity is not valid.
Right? So let's go back to the GitHub
action.
That GitHub action generates a JWT.
Great.
You can use that JWT
to get a certificate and sign your image.
Who kicked off that action? Was it kicked
off by a logged in user?
Did somebody commit some code that that was
a part of? Did that person have correct
access to that repo?
So that's an identity problem. That's not a
a key problem. Now let's get back to
the idea of, okay.
I've generated this this cert.
Think about it from a GitOps standpoint.
You're gonna have usually two repos. Right? You're
gonna have a code repo and a,
infrastructure repo.
Your code repo runs.
You want it to update your infrastructure repo
to say, okay. Here's the new version of
my image.
And then you've gotta get that infrastructure repo
into your cluster.
You're gonna use something like Argo or Flux.
Right? But how do you know that all
those things that are talking together are doing
it with a real identity, a unique identity,
and that identity that you can trust?
And so the supply chain problem
now becomes an identity
problem, not a key management problem,
to solve or at least a big part
of it. And then you're increasing the security
of your environment now because now everything's talking
with these short lived keys and specific identities.
And so everything else comes for the ride.
And so going back to the where we're
talking earlier about, you know, my service account
talks to my cluster.
If you're using that static service account from
outside the cluster, the identities that are generated
from anything that gets created by that static
service account are now in question because you
have it's much harder to verify.
So I'm actually gonna be out at Identiverse.
Well, it's next week now. I don't know
when this is gonna publish. It's it's the
June,
and that's actually an identity management focused conference
talking about this and showing a a
doing a lab of how do you securely
provision your environment to actually
get out of Sigstore
what you're hoping to get out of it.
It it's it's kinda like
I I like to explain it as it
wasn't the astronomers
that solved
cross Atlantic navigation.
It was the watchmakers.
It's not gonna be the cryptographers
that signed supply chain security.
It's gonna be the identity management experts
because it it it's that lower level problem
that then bubbles up to everything else.
Awesome.
I think that monologue is a pretty good
way to end the episode. That
was great. Thank you. Alright, Mark. It's been
an absolute pleasure. Thank you so much for
your time today and for sharing all of
this wonderful security information with me and with
the audience.
Please take a moment now to give us
more information on your company, your products, any
shameless plugs, anything at all that you want
to share before we finish up. Yeah. And
thanks for having me, David. I always have
a blast.
So you wanna learn how to, you know,
simplify access to your clusters? Go to openunison.github.io.
All our stuff is open source. Everything's documented
there. You can ask issues on GitHub. Happy
to handle there. And, of course, support contracts,
always available.
And then if you're interested in
using our CICD proxy
for for managing access for your clusters from
your workflows, that is cicdproxy.github.io.
Again, % open source
and,
yeah, helps you automate that as well. That'll
do your ingress controllers. That'll do your RBAC
rules that simplifies that entire deployment process for
you. Alright. Thank you very much.